s'installer à sa machine à coudre un
geste que pascal brain pratique chaque
jour ses doigts créé costumes de scène
et costumes d'époque les costumes
d'époque étaient construits à la main
donc les techniques sont différentes
quand on passe à la machine à coudre on
n'a pas forcément la place de passer la
machine à coudre donc il faut qu'on joue
conte russe con quand on veut gagner du
temps et ne pas le faire à la main c'est
combien d'heures de travail entre 60 et
70 heures de travail
rien qu'en confection
mais quand il en avait parlé je l'avais
déjà dans la tête je savais qu'elle
manteau je voulais lui faire j'avais une
idée de manteaux renaissance cette
yvelinoise lance en 2014 son entreprise
au fil de l'histoire avec son fils celle
qui coûte depuis l'âge de 7 ans est
autodidacte ont fait en effet on essaie
à ce que ça ressemble d'abord avec nous
qu'on a pris dans dans son armoire et qu
on copie et puis on va démonter on
essaie d'y arriver le plus près possible
puis ça se fait tout seul parce qu'elle
prenne coup pour des châteaux les amis
de charles perrault et la troupe
saint-quentinoise la troupe du crâne
c'est une femme justement dans les
coulisses qui hélas toujours aux petits
soins qui va veiller au moindre détail
qui aussi à l'autorité qu'il faut pour
gérer des coulisses parce que ça c'est
vraiment très important de gérer une
équipe de 12 personnes ou voire plus les
commandes que nous faisons à pascal
elles sont importantes
ça peut être tout un vestiaire a créé
sur une thématique précise
un costume représente jusqu'à un mois de
travail la recette pour faire un bond
dans le passé